oh yeah okay hello and welcome to this
video I've lost a couple of points in
the last video because I played
typically idiotic cheater yeah I didn't
feel like posting this video it was
again blatantly obvious what was going
on I reported him he will be banned and
life goes on okay so let's see what
happens against mr. ESO call um yeah I'm
not an expert in the commune's Indian so
we'll see what happens here try to
experimental but ok so our interesting
way of playing c5 he can take Bishop
takes and this is hanging them ok
problem and should develop him Oh
interesting
should I go a five threatening Bishop
before very cheap trick I don't want to
play on cheap tricks let's play normal
moves okay my development is good this
is this is nice but he still has got the
the bishop pan and some some tactics
going on here hmm mm-hmm okay i can go i
have six seven but let's see problem
against his players he's playing instant
moves all the time and they are not that
bad I've lost lots of games on time
against him my score is minus three it
was much worse but recent games I'm
squat properly okay and I bishop won't
be seven is a problem here
so you got night 85-year of course yeah
instantly I has to be played instantly
never think everything is obvious okay
okay sop8 you may be okay so let's
didn't see that you cannot cancel of
course instantly yeah but you still have
to refute this stuff it's it's just bad
but it has to be refuted in about three
minutes so what you do five is a good
move I that allows us check probably not
so echo here just get everything in play
and Bishop deform can be an option here
and going for that they might be able to
take and castle huh I actually that I
should have reconsidered you might be
able to get away with this just being
yeah like this get into some kind of bad
ending that you can still play but
rookie for is interesting here in this
position check as king on the FI loses
immediately so he has to step onto the D
file there should be two daz night f4
so check j no neither for it wince now
what am I we're looking here white
resigns yeah I'm sorry for being a bit
sarcastic but I was a history with this
person it's like always playing move
move move in the most complicated
positions and I'm always feel I always
feel good if I refute this kind of plane
okay mmm so yeah this is probably some
kind of theoretical line but I really
don't know 95 I already think is
questionable I don't see why you would
move the light again ok I can actually
grab a pawn on e4 but ok I wanted to
develop and just try to use my better
development him yeah yeah it has this
ideas of knight c6 so I cannot maybe I
can do that but I was kind of afraid
this is possible ok I would have six is
not a bad man friend yeah just just
developing it I have got the much better
development here I came here here 95 and
okay i can actually already refute this
a completely with this oops I'm sorry
you should be five yeah Black is clearly
better didn't see that only this but
this is also better than pluck yeah and
now it is very nice and the bishop on c5
prevents his castling rights this one
yes very it's a very loosely yeah bishop
t4 is debatable ok this is winning
immediately and all that's a very cool
move by the engine Wow
yeah I mean okay White has committed
many sins so there should be some
punishment but okay I didn't see that
one only this and this isn't that great
i mean i'm i'm in good shape but it's
not like i'm winning the engine wants to
play g3 simply accepting jack the
capture him and I'm epona but the engine
doesn't really think it's that great and
he's getting this getting something back
here cannot keep you six yeah this is
jag losing immediately check and until
he resigned yeah I really have it it's
just one of my couple of things I simply
cannot stand I cannot stand if people
playing sand moves in super complicated
positions I mean this is some spot that
I really am sorry and with bitter that
sometimes but I really like to punish
this kind of play I think it's just not
a good way of playing chess if it's
complicated should think at least a
little but you cannot just play any move
and okay anyway thanks for watching